and then trump again playing up the  victim stuff saying he's the most  persecuted person in american history  again another part of the speech that  the crowd was silent during a friend of  mine recently said  that i was the most persecuted person in  the history of our country me the most  persecuted i never thought it that way i  never had time i was always fighting  with these people that were trying to  persecute me  i didn't have time to think about being  persecuted because i was fighting  persecution  when i thought about it though i sit  back he's a very smart guy successful  i thought set back i said you know  he may very well be right  certainly there's been no politician or  president treated like i've been treated  right no one's been treated worse than  trump as he continues to remind us